good afternoon sorry for the delay but
at least at what she told me Samantha
was finishing what would you finish in
an op-ed for the New York Times tomorrow
okay well i'm ernesto CDU director of
the Yale Center for the Study of
globalization I thank you for being here
this afternoon it is my pleasure to
welcome Samantha power back to her
University samantha is a graduate of
Yale College and of the Harvard Law
School
and she's also the founding executive
director of the Carr Center for human
rights at the Kennedy School of Harvard
University where she's also a lecturer
despite her youth Samantha is already
recognized both as a leading expert on
human rights and u.s. foreign policy and
as an accomplished journalist in fact
her impressive dramatic and very
professional account of u.s. foreign
policy vis-a-vis some terrible episodes
of genocide earned her the Pulitzer
Prize last year with this book a problem
from Hell America and the age of
genocide samantha has kindly accepted to
speak this afternoon about American
foreign policy in an age of terror and
afterwards to engage in a dialogue with
those of you who may want to pursue
further the topic of this afternoon's
conversation dear friends let's welcome
Samantha power
walk away with a watch of a president
it's great to be here thank you all of
you for coming out I'm sorry we
scheduled this on Passover but at least
we were able to get some of you in
attendance it's a great thrill to come
back to Yale and I do teach at Harvard
now but there just is no comparison and
when I last returned I had the the
singular terrifying experience of my
professional and academic and personal
life which was that my senior essay
advisor Gaddis Smith was the respondent
on my book about a week into the books
life and I believe not only did I
surprise it but or did I survive the the
ordeal but Gaddis the teacher and the
greater that he is was the first to say
to me this book is gonna win the
Pulitzer Prize I tell you there's a
warrant this book is destined for awards
I said you're crazy this book is barely
bested for publication you know but it's
both as always intimidating to be here
in front of my former teachers for it's
true B's here as well I see and and but
it's also a great thrill what I'm going
to do is not talk about genocide my
piece for tomorrow's paper is actually
on something bordering on genocide
anyway that's occurring in western Sudan
in Darfur and as many of you know this
is the ten year anniversary this week of
the Rwandan genocide so there's an awful
lot of yammering again about never again
and it doesn't seem as if our mechanisms
are any better oiled or readied to
respond to cases of ethnically
derived slaughter and and deportation so
we can talk about that in the question
period if you'd like but what I thought
I would do is talk about terrorism u.s.
foreign policy and human rights and
basically ask what can the relationship
between human rights and national
security be and what should it be
in an age of terror something pretty
dramatic happened going on now six
months ago in Washington which is that
George Bush stood up at the American
Enterprise Institute and he delivered
what has now become known as the age of
Liberty speech now Bush as you know
probably in his national security
strategy document stressed human rights
and and liberty and dignity and freedom
more than any president actually in
American history he used the term the
phrase in this natural security strategy
doctrine human rights use that phrase
five times human dignity nine times
Liberty 11 times democracy 13 times and
freedom which is of course the favorite
formulation 46 times this age of Liberty
speech which would come a couple years
after there the national security
strategy document was unveiled used the
phrase or the term freedom 40 times and
Liberty 18 times but much more
interesting than the kind of Nod to
freedom and and to Liberty that that has
been kind of steady not actually now for
the last couple years since 9/11 and a
little bit before but but really a
ramping up was the content of the speech
and I'm just gonna read you a short
portion of the speech again many of you
have probably already seen it but what
Bush said in front of the American
Enterprise Institute he said some
skeptics of democracy assert that the
traditions of Islam are inhospitable to
representative government this cultural
condescension as Ronald Reagan termed it
has a long history after the Japanese
surrender in 1945 a so-called Japan
expert asserted that democracy in that
former Empire would quote never work
another observer declared that the
prospects for democracy in post Hitler
Germany
and I quote or he quotes most uncertain
at best he made that claim in 1957 time
after time observers have questioned
whether this country or that people or
this group are ready for democracy as if
freedom were a prize you win for meeting
our own Western standards of progress
this is George Bush speaking it should
be clear to all that Islam the faith of
one-fifth of humanity is consistent with
democratic rule Turkey Indonesia Senegal
Albania Niger Sierra Leone more than
half of all Muslims in the world live in
freedom under democratically constituted
governments they succeed in democratic
societies not in spite of their faith
but because of it and here's where he
says something really interesting and
radical he says sixty years of Western
nations excusing and accommodating the
lack of freedom in the Middle East did
nothing to make us safe because in the
long run stability cannot be purchased
at the expense of Liberty now this is a
kind of radical idea one because it is a
an acknowledgement of past bad policies
mistaken policies backing of repressive
regimes and that actually coming back to
haunt us now it's a diffusion of
responsibilities not 60 years of America
backing its Western nations so it's us
as part of something larger
but accommodating lack of freedom
appeasing effectively he's saying is at
odds with our the enjoyment of our long
term Liberty as long as the Middle East
remains a place where freedom does not
flourish it will remain a place of
stagnation resentments and violence
ready for export and with the spread of
weapons of course that can bring
catastrophic harm to our country and to
our friends it would be reckless to
accept the status quo okay there are two
ways that one can interpret this and
what I'm going to do today is talk about
why even if we I'll tell you about the
two ways in the second but even if we
give it the charitable interpretation
and take at its face this kind of
murmuring in Washington now about
democratization and the at a minimum
even if we're not seeing policy outcomes
yet a recognition somewhere in the kind
of bowels of
a variety of institutions including even
the Pentagon but a recognition that
interests and values can't actually be
compartmentalized in the way that they
have been for basically the entire
existence of this country and certainly
in the last 50 years that they can't be
compartmentalize that in fact you know
perceiving national interest is being
narrowly defined in terms of security
and economic interest if you don't
actually incorporate concern for human
rights and liberalisation of these
societies then you will privilege your
short-term security actually often at
the expense of your long-term security
so even if this if we take take this at
its face the two ways we can do it we
can we can cynically say you know this
is all just rhetoric just like the war
in Iraq was about other things you know
you know sort of grounded in in the
language of freedom and genocide
suppression or pre-emptive prevention or
retrospective punishment or something
but it was really all about oil it was
all about Daddy or it was all about
weapons that weren't there but that they
thought were there they didn't think was
there but thought might be useful to say
we're there or it was about the
Terrorism link or was just about beating
somebody up in the Middle East once in a
while so as to show the rest of the
region that you mean business
whatever you think the realpolitik
motive was you could hear this speech
and say a same old same old
you know you rhetoric Yammer Yammer
Yammer but in fact foreign policy will
be made you know in the way that it's
always been made on behalf of these
security and economic interest in Iraq
is witness we're testament to that the
this interpretation I think brings to
mind
Gandhi's remark when he was asked about
what he thought about Christianity this
Bush is sort of laying talk about
freedom what Gandhi said when he was
asked about what he thought about
Christian Christianity he said it's a
marvelous idea someone should try it
sometime and I think that is the
reaction that many have to Bush's
language which is freedom yeah it's a
good thing we'd like to see some
evidence of some policy changes in the
face of this so-called recognition but
there's another interpretation which I'm
going to take at least as as mine for
today's purposes which is that there is
this recognition
mentioned in Washington that values and
interests actually belonged together
that they have to be intertwined there
is there are people looking around and
seeing a correlative connection between
nuclear proliferation and arms shipments
to other countries and a Carly
connection between that and human rights
records North Korea Iraq Pakistan Iran
arguably also of course one just looks
at the 9/11 hijackers and takes note for
all the talk of the axis of evil that
the hijackers themselves of course came
not from axis of evil countries but from
Saudi Arabia and Egypt US allies there
is something going on
somewhere in which the shortsightedness
taught by Gaddis smith of course forever
here at yale of the idea of the enemy of
my enemy is my friend or he may be a son
of a [ __ ] but he's our son of a [ __ ]
that short short sightedness of that i
think is has become apparent to some
people that we can talk about who and
and what good it does in a minute but
there is even having said that i do want
to issue this caveat that even with
those people there is something very
instrumental now about what freedom is
that is it's still about us it's still
about advancing promoting democracy
because we don't want those societies to
become threats to us so the the end even
at again at its best where you actually
have this this recognition they only
matter insofar as they become a threat
to us and of course that has great
bearing in societies like Zimbabwe or
Sierra Leone or Sudan where where
interest is either seen to cut in favor
still of security interests are seen to
cut in favor of backing repressive
regimes or at least turning a blind eye
to atrocities or again in Zimbabwe in
Sierra Leone countries that have no
bearing whatsoever on
on terrorism at least again in the short
term so you will see in this framework
even if again we take it it's at its
face that certain countries who can't
offer an al-qaeda connection might well
be excluded or simply forgotten in this
new you know alleged commitment to an
age of liberty but let's just take again
this idea that something's going on and
people are debating and they're trying
to think about how to roll up their
sleeves and what liberalisation means
and let me talk if I could first about
some structural challenges to
integrating human rights into u.s.
foreign policy that actually have very
little to do with George Bush but have
to do with the nature of how foreign
policy is carried out and then the
second part of the talk to talk
specifically about what Bush has done
and could do to make this a more viable
project if in fact a critical mass ever
comes together to make it a sincere
project first structurally and some of
this will sound very obvious to you but
I think it's worth saying because there
is we do bring a certain incredulity
until we get jaded of course to some of
the ways in which human rights is not
factored in a foreign policy or at least
I do but one point of course
structurally that is a great
disadvantage for potential victims of
atrocity and and of human rights abuse
is that victims don't vote human rights
abuses carried out overseas penalize
people who are not relevant political
actors in this society but more
fundamental than that human rights
issues even for those of us who care
about human rights or think we care are
not for us voting issues so let me give
the best example that I can give which
is one that involved myself I spent
almost a decade unearthing US responses
to genocide and getting these government
documents Declassified and just looking
at the kind of banality of bystander
hood and the bureaucratic of allowing
genocide I mean this monstrous crime and
got more familiar than I ever wanted to
be with the Clinton administration and
its high and low level officials who
were involved in shaping
we're not shaping these policies and
when it came time for me to vote the - I
have to say the two most recent
genocides of course would have been that
in Bosnians repre Nitza
and that in Rwanda in 1994 these two
genocides just happened I'm living in
the thick of trying to understand who
did what when where in why and who
didn't do what and when it came time for
me to vote in 1996 did did Bill
Clinton's response to Rwanda or cerebra
Nitze have any bearing on how I voted in
that election well if it had I would
have voted for Bob Dole because Bob Dole
was not on Rwanda exactly but but on
Bosnia was you know a major energizer
actually of a US response but without
saying who I did vote for it let me just
say I didn't vote for Bob Dole and and I
don't think I'm unusual and and I don't
mean this even that I'm partisan or that
I come in with some that the fix is
necessarily in every time I go to the
voting booth but but when you when you
are living in a society it is the issues
that confront you that surround you that
tend to be what you define your
relationship to your leader on the basis
of and and you know many of us I suppose
would have to ask ourselves you know if
George Bush did the right thing let's
say on Sudan or suddenly decided to
spearhead a peacekeeping effort outside
of you Tory in Congo or or if he had
moved US soldiers off that ship off the
coast of Liberia and actually you know
put troops in harm's way we can talk
we're going to talk in a second about
whether US military intervention can be
appropriate in light of the lack of
legitimacy associated with US power but
if you did all those things would that
change your opinion of him would it
change your vote would it you know what
would it do well for most people it may
change your opinion at the margins but
it probably won't change your vote
second point about foreign policy is
again quite obvious but is that what the
framers brought to this country was a
spectacular pessimism about human nature
and a spectacular prophecy and they
built in
to our system checks and balances born
of the recognition that we are selfish
and that we actually can't trust
ourselves so not only do we have checks
and balances in local state and federal
government not only do we have three
branches of government executive
legislative and judicial and not only
does the judiciary have control
technically over the tyranny of the
majority within applying the bill of
rights against legislation I mean all of
this is is there but we also have of
course civil society groups and voters
and other forms of checks and the press
and so on domestically but all of this
is predicated on the idea that we can't
actually trust people in power to look
out for minority rights to look out for
the important as well as the urgent and
we need these structures it's a whole
system predicated on our ability and our
selfishness there's nothing like this in
place of course for foreign policy so
the same kind of short-termism and
desire to privilege us let's say at the
expense of them whoever them are is of
course going to be with us in the
context of foreign policy third
structural problem is has to do with I
think the moral imagination even in
instances where the subject of distance
suffering comes up in government and
keep in mind that one things you hear if
you interview US officials especially
those during the Clinton years it's
actually less true today but it's what
people will tell you is if you make a
moral argument in government you're not
going to get invited to the next meeting
again that's less true in the Bush
administration you can make a moral
argument whatever happens with it I
don't know or whether it's you know
corrupted in a variety of ways we'll
leave that aside for a second but but
even when you can make a moral argument
and you can actually bring up the fate
of the rwandan s-- or in the case of
let's say it was Becca Stan today where
people apparently were boiled to death
last month in Uzbekistan by the
government that we remained aligned with
in the interest of being able to use
their bases for entry into Afghanistan
elsewhere in Central Asia but even if
that comes up in a meeting the ability
to kind of go there
and actually put yourself there and to
in to acquire the kind of knowledge that
isn't just abstract knowledge of human
suffering but that is knee buckling you
know gut wrenching you know like
literally like a punch in the tummy or
the kind of knowledge that makes you cry
as if it were somebody you knew that
kind of knowledge is very hard to
acquire so in the case of let's say some
of the genocides I looked at of course
you know in Rwanda we knew a hundred
thousand that we knew three hundred
thousand we even knew bodies bobbing
down the river and we even had footage
of people killing other people but to
stop and actually imagine you know your
little boy being reduced to pleading you
know to a machete-wielding Rwandan
extremists please don't kill me I'll
never be Tutsi again which is what
happened and and then being a mother and
watching that young boy be struck down
that's a very different kind of
knowledge that's the knowledge that
freezes a number or an abstract sort of
set of sufferings and and and and sort
of disaggregates it into its constituent
individual parts and not many of us
bring that kind of imagination to the
office every morning so what you get are
manifest risks to American interests and
either security or economic or you know
just in terms of the financial cost of
getting involved or you giving up bases
or something very very tangible on the
one hand and something quite remote and
abstract and often in places where very
few of us and very few officials have
ever actually visited or acquainted
themselves with in any kind of deep way
so when it comes to human rights in u.s.
foreign policy we tend to inhabit a kind
of twilight between knowing and not
knowing even if the facts are available
to us fourth point is that in order to
override the long-standing default
proposition which is that American
foreign policy is about economic and
security interests domestic political
pressure is necessary and I alluded to
this and in the voting context but when
it comes to human rights there's a major
mobilization gap in this country and in
in most states in the sense that we may
all in fact there may be a majority of
us out
there who are ripe to be led on human
rights related issues actually even ripe
to give something up whether money or
even to risk you know American
technology or even American soldiers in
the case of genocide or something like
that that rightness that constituency
might be out there but the very
universalism of human rights the thing
that might make us all kind of Nod when
somebody makes a good argument on behalf
of a Chinese dissident or an Uzbek you
know more recently that universalism
doesn't create the particular connection
that gets us out of our chairs and so
what you see I think is a mobilization
gap between a kind of passive
constituency that we hope exists that
might exist and the folks who actually
you know who get out and and and move
and make noise and change policy or at
least influence policy and either in
creating a constraint on policy the
perception that something is undoable
you know that there will be a price to
be paid if you do do something or an
enabling constituency and you see this
recently actually in the context of
Sudan the tremendous effect actually
that the Religious Right has had in this
country in getting the Bush
administration to take seriously the
atrocities carried out by Khartoum
against rebels in the South but also
Christian civilians in the south of
Sudan and and very very high-level
leadership that is about was about to
culminate in a peace accord that would
end you know more than 20 years civil
war and that's about a particular
connection that's about saying okay
they're like us Sudan as a whole didn't
get anybody and we're with the big test
for the expansiveness of human
connections is can this particular
connection now be harnessed and turned
to focus on Horrors carried out against
African Muslims it's a big question so
far the peace process has not turned but
that is the peril of particularism same
is true with religious freedom
legislation and so on it's very very
sensitive to crackdowns on Christians
but far less so against other abuses
against the nature of the lobbies that
are made
that are putting these laws in place
that are creating noise ethnic lobbies
of course tend to get created in the
ethnic lobbies that turn up in this
country tend to get created by
atrocities or by genocide look at the
Armenian Lobby here even the Jewish
community certainly the Albanians played
a really really important role in
actually helping generate intervention
in Kosovo but these lobbies tend to come
about you know on the far side of great
suffering you see this point about
politics and human rights I think also
very notably in the Guantanamo context
where you you know became very clear who
the privileged detainees actually were
they were privileged on the basis of
where they'd been picked up or what they
had done or been alleged to have done or
in the case of Guantanamo thought
because many people are detained just on
the basis of intent rather than action
or alleged intent but it was actually on
the basis of citizenship it was whose
government spoke the loudest and had the
most clout so it wasn't a coincidence at
all that the British in the Australian
suspects were told that there would be
no death penalty for them then they were
the first to get counsel and then they
were the first to get to go home so I
think that's again more analogous than
directly on point to domestic
constituencies but mobilization is such
a huge part of what will actually put
human rights center stage in or on the
stage in in Washington fifth point is
that international institutions that one
might turn to for aid in this domain are
notoriously defective the Security
Council of course has its problems its
membership is anachronistic and
unrepresentative of power or population
and of culture it has on it of course
Russia which is committing has been
committing crimes against humanity in
Chechnya China which of course has a
dreadful human rights record and and
these are structures of course not just
at the Security Council but elsewhere
within the UN system that were put in
place a long time ago to deal
very very different threats and
contingencies so but as a matter of
domestic politics just want to stress
I'm going to come back to this the UN is
many things and the Security Council of
course is the most visible to Americans
who confuse all its time many of us do
in fact what when the UN is actually
serving as a stage and when it is an
actor in and of itself in a variety of
ways which again I'll come to but when
we see the Security Council it is
experienced by Americans simply in terms
of the constraint that it that it places
on American power we we aren't relying
on the UN as an actor to supply
humanitarian a we're not relying for the
rule of law on UN courts for the Rwanda
or for former Yugoslavia we always see
of the UN is is it's that body that
couldn't endorse intervention in Kosovo
or Iraq that got in our way twice and I
think sort of fleshing out the
complexity of that structure is very
very important we see it's cumbersome
bureaucratic tendencies and it's angry
General Assembly and we note of course
that the General Assembly for months
session is actually still scheduled on
the steam ship schedules from nineteen
from the 1940s that's why we have the
four-month session that we do it's still
correlated to the steamship you know
that's what people see the UN that's
what they associate with the UN but one
of the other reasons and this will bring
me the second part of the talk I'll go
through quickly one of the other reasons
that it's really difficult now to inject
human rights into foreign policy apart
from all these structural impediments is
that we aren't terribly welcomed when in
fact we put our minds to something like
humanitarian intervention and I should
say this was true even before George
Bush took office there is very little
trusts out there in the world about
American motives and and certainly in
the context of nation-building exercises
there's zero trust in America staying
power and they're related I mean the
feeling is
that we get in get what we want and you
know the case of Bosnia or Kosovo where
we got in for mainly humanitarian
reasons it was also clear to people in
the in on the ground and in the world
that even though those were the reasons
the cause was that it had become
politically costly to do nothing and so
of course then you get involved quickly
you do away with the cost because you're
seen to be acting but then you get out
before you've actually had time to do
justice to the to the people in whose
name you've actually intervened which
which isn't to say that non intervention
would have been preferable but it is to
say that there's a great discrepancy
between the amount that is spent and the
resources committed to kind of military
suppression and then the kind of the
wandering eye or the the lack of
attention span when it comes to the
follow-through which is where of course
societies are built and rule of law is
created so that that people will be able
to control their own destinies so we're
in a kind of peculiar place when it
comes to this you know misnomer of
humanitarian intervention in that the
only people in the world who think that
the East Timor ease the cost of ours and
the Afghans are any better off after the
wars that America was a part of carrying
out in those countries the only people
who think that they were better off are
the East Timor ease the cost of ours and
the Afghans so we've we've lost
legitimacy and that much is clear and
let me now turn to why we've lost
legitimacy and and how actually despite
all of these structural defects with
top-down leadership of the kind that
could actually be conceivably mustered
in the face of a perception of a threat
which is what we have now is that this
feeling that all bets are off that all
systems have to be rethought that we get
to start anew but a variety of things
would really have to change in order for
the u.s. to have the legitimacy I think
and to be effective in the realm of
human rights promotion and to have any
part of an age of liberty so let me just
sketch a few of the things that I think
absolutely would have to be done even
again just assuming that we had the kind
of top-down leadership that might
overcome some of the the premises in in
the last section of the talk which which
were about domestic political pressures
and consider
and institutions and how difficult it is
to find them and to service them you
know on the human rights front so here
that some of the things that I think
George Bush has to tackle if he's going
to go forward in in rhetoric in in
practice in the way that he has been of
late rhetorically first of all again
this is all about legitimacy the United
States is more unilateralis now than it
ever has been in its history American
exceptionalism is not at all new the
presumption of American purity the
disproportionate power even it's not
mean it's greater disproportion perhaps
now but Europe is more of a rival so
arguably it's you know but this is not
we've been more powerful than everyone
else for quite a long time
we have exempted ourselves from
international treaties and from
international institutions and from
judgments that don't suit us and I think
all of this actually frankly should be
rethought that the tradition of
exceptionalism is very short-sighted but
George Bush is taking the unilateralism
to a new place and let me just give you
a couple examples of things you've
probably heard of where there is a
feeling that it's actually an ideology
of unilateralism or gratuitous
unilateralism actually that it's not
even tactically in our interest to be as
hostile as we are being to international
institutions and a couple of these
things might might actually surprise you
you know of course that the the Bush
administration is has set out to kill
the International Criminal Court which
is of course brand-new and hasn't had
any time even to engender the wrath in
terms of its actual policies or
investigations of this administration
but this is again an ideological belief
shared by the Clinton ministration that
this Court will not serve US interest
that it will only be hostile to the
United States now what you may not know
though is in addition to wanting to kill
the court in addition to unsigned the
Rome treaty which is what John Bolton
did you know soon after George Bush took
office he called it the the the greatest
moment of his life was taking white out
to the US signature on the
Rome treaty but in addition to that we
actually have a piece of legislation
that passed in 2002 as part of something
called the American servicemembers
Protection Act that has within it
something called The Hague invasion
clause now what the Hague invasion
Clause authorizes u.s. forces to do is
to invade Holland in fact to liberate
u.s. soldiers or US citizens who are
unjustly detained in again the
Netherlands if you're thinking about
building alliances and and if you're
certainly if you're thinking about
fighting a war on terrorism and
generating kind of systemic cooperation
across borders and and dealing with
transnational threats of the kind that
obviously are facing this country and
others having sort of pieces of
legislation in the Congress of course is
implicated in this fully that that
authorized the invasion of an ally that
actually was supportive of the war in
Iraq is not probably a good practice the
second example in the context of the
International Criminal Court is these
bilateral treaties that we've been
negotiating with a variety of countries
to try to get them to promise if US I
mean it's such a long stretch kind of
hypothetical that would have to happen
in order for any of this stuff to come
into play but if the ICC were to
investigate or were to announce that it
wanted to investigate it a crime
committed that rival genocide systematic
crimes against humanity or systemic war
crimes if it the ICC announced this and
the United States chose not to
investigate it itself which would of
course if it did investigate it would
preempt the ICC's jurisdiction so it'd
be a good thing to do you can get then
you don't have to invade Holland but if
you if the u.s. chose not to investigate
on the grounds that it was a trumped up
charge and the ICC went forward with his
investigation and somehow the US soldier
or citizen in question ended up in a
particular country such that that
country that was a signatory to the Rome
treaty to the ICC would have to turn
that person over to the court in that
event the United States has negotiated
these bilateral treaties with these
countries getting them
the signatories to promise not to turn
over such a US citizen who would have
been involved in committing genocide
okay so that's that's the spirit behind
the bilateral treaties we've got a lot
of them I think we've now got maybe 2/3
of the signatories have signed on and
agreed not to turn over a US personnel
that many of these countries are new
democracies who were just you know
embedding themselves within
international institutions in
international law so getting them
immediately to violate international law
with bilateral treaties is not a good
thing but moreover some countries have
stood up and said no we're actually not
going to sign away our right to comply
with the treaty that we've already
signed we will take the punishment and
believe it or not what the United States
has done is actually cut off military
aid to two countries who've contributed
troops to Iraq so you actually have
countries in Iraq that are serving
alongside the United States in that
escapade and who are getting less
military assistance because they have
again insisted on complying with the
international law that they've already
signed we also have two countries that
are partners in our drug interdiction
efforts that we've cut off again
military and system assistance two and
three kind of nascent democracies like
Croatia and other countries that are
trying to stem nationalist tides but
again who have been greeted you know
with an aid cutoff now again it's
military aid whatever one thinks about
military aid but certainly from the bush
administration standpoint many of these
cases this does seem to be an instance
of kind of cutting off our noses despite
our faces second example I want to give
briefly is is the Global Health Fund for
HIV TB and malaria the bush ministration
course made a much voluntad announcement
of allocating 15 billion over five years
not all not even most of that money of
course in year one has turned up yet but
notably the Bush administration went to
the mat to bypass again one of the few
international institutions that hasn't
yet had time to screw up which is the
Global Health Fund which is actually
bringing to it the very metrics and the
kind of McKinsey approach of
accountability and follow-through on
you know investment as it were in
prevention treatment and care
initiatives but the but the bush
ministration again here's here's an
opportunity to we and the the
announcement was made not at all
coincidentally while Bush was making the
case to go to war in Iraq so this was
meant to offset some of the hostility
toward the United States engendered by
the war and yet the way we do it the way
we carried out almost on you know just
as a matter of ideology is to bypass an
institution that already exists that is
assembling a pretty good track record
again it hasn't been in place long
enough for it to be a an extensive track
record but what do we have to do then in
terms of USAID and bilateral fund we
have to make it all up we have to do
exactly what they're doing and just
replicate it internally so again I think
an example of gratuitous unilateralism I
think it's important to stress that the
UN which is where unilateralism most
often it takes form is many many things
and it and it is very difficult I think
to speak clearly about the institution
in a way that all people can understand
at once it is a stage for big power
exchanges and it is of course as I said
an actor in its own right it is the UN
Secretariat after the NATO bombed Kosovo
that came in and ran the virtual
Protectorate there it is the World Food
Program part of the UN that averted
famine in Afghanistan after the Taliban
were dislodged and which this again
might surprise you in the Iraqi war it
was the UN that kept Iraqis fed by June
of last year the UN was delivering a
thousand tons of food an hour around the
clock and by the end of October to
deliver 2.2 million tons of food worth
1.5 billion dollars now this was food
funded by the US and the UK but it
couldn't have been delivered by the
soldiers and what none of us knew while
all this you know skirmishing was going
on in New York was that covert
negotiations were going on by which the
World Food Program was going to team up
with US forces in order to make sure
that e rakhis didn't die and imagine as
bad as the bedlam was given the lack or
the insufficient pre-war planning
imagine how much worse it would have
been if those if that 1.5 billion hadn't
been dispersed and let's continue with
what the UN did in Iraq
again did in Iraq where supposedly
discredited it was UN Special
Representative Sergio Vieira de Mello
who convinced Paul Bremer
to change his scheme for advisors he was
going to just come in actually on the
model of what surgery was done in East
Timor as a kind of Raj and have a team
of advisers but it was Sergio who had
had the experience in East Timor and in
Kosovo Kim said you can't do advisors to
you you have to have a governing council
call it something else and make it
something else
was the UN who persuaded Bremer to
create that institution turns out it was
UN inspectors who convinced Saddam
Hussein to destroy his weapons of mass
destruction who knew and I think the
important thing really to to point out
when it comes to the UN is is it was
never said better than by dog Hamish
Cole the second secretary-general by the
way Kofi Annan says SG secretary-general
stands not for secretary general but for
SG scapegoat but but Hamish gold said
the UN was not created to take humanity
to heaven but to save it from hell and I
think that at least in the humanitarian
function and the agency the actor
function of the UN is what it can do it
is best and I could say many negative
things about the UN to but I'll save
that for the discussion second point and
I'm running a little bit out of time now
but is after unilateralism a historicism
is I think fatal to American legitimacy
Ernesto and I were speaking about a
little bit in the in the car but I think
America has to recognize all states
should recognize but America because of
its disproportionate power in the way
that it is watched and the way that even
its mere words like we sort of sneeze
and there's a tidal wave the way it can
unleash a tidal wave in other countries
but but that history matters we have to
recognize that and that people are
keeping score across a much broader
stretch of time and and much broader
scope there's something quite admirable
about America's forward-looking spirit
there's a kind of optimism where every
leader comes into power and says the
clock starts anew today with me but in
fact we inherit in the eyes of those
affected by past
seize the policies and effects of those
policies of our predecessors I think
just to give an example when : Powell
went for instance to halabja the scene
of one of the more gruesome attacks by
Saddam Hussein carried out against the
Kurds in 1988 five thousand people
murdered with chemical weapons : Pal was
of course Nash security advisor during
the period where the chemical attacks
took place and of course the US response
at the time was to double aid to
Saddam's regime while he was carrying
out those attacks now it wasn't we
didn't double our aid of course because
of those attacks but genocide was not as
I shown at all in and of itself
something that would cause policy to
turn it was it was sort of an incidental
factor to be taken into consideration or
really only at the margins so because we
were we wanted to double our aid the
farm Lobby wanted to give Saddam more
money to buy American farm products that
happened the genocide wasn't gonna play
a role but when Colin Powell goes to
Halabja and pays a tribute to the
victims and the lives that are lost
there for him to miss that opportunity
to make mention of what the u.s.
position had been at the time of the
l'objet seems to me again is a wasted
opportunity it was one that was noted by
everybody there contrast that with :
Powell's response to a question on the
eve of the war in Iraq where a young
woman said what do you secretary Powell
how can you the United States go to war
in Iraq and the name of Human Rights
after everything you've done around the
world I mean look at what you did in
Chile with a yen day and and Powell said
off-the-cuff clearly without clearance
that is an event of which we are not
proud but our tactics have changed and
here all the good reasons we should we
have to go to war in Iraq well here's an
instance I read about this on a 20-7 in
the New York Times and then went to the
Chilean the websites of Mercurio and
Nazi on the two major papers thinking oh
there's probably some op-ed coverage
here this will probably surprise people
that we actually just said we're not
proud of having been involved in
assassinating a foreign leader and
bedcover to go the up and page there's a
few things I go to the front page
there's no text on the front page
of the major papers it's just a single
photo of the palace on fire with a and a
in it and it just says Mia culpa
at last Powell says us not proud so the
extent to which even the scraps are
taken third point and I'll wrap with
this is unilateralism a historicism ala
carte ISM this is this is I think really
where the rubber meets the road this is
where if we're serious about giving
speeches about backing repressive
regimes and and and if we could actually
unpack that and even get into a little
more detail to make people feel
recognized and what they've gone through
in their societies even if we got the
history right there is a way in which
and this is true is human nature as well
as state policies generally but where we
we look at issues within the four
corners of the issue itself without
seeing the ways in which the decisions
we make in other areas utterly infect
our ability to get what we want or to
make arguments that are heard on their
face in a particular context so take the
argument for war in Iraq when the Bush
administration went to the Security
Council it really thought that it was
losing the debate over the war near Ike
either out of kind of European Craven
as' or because somehow it wasn't
succeeding in persuading people about
the merits of these argument out that
the most of the argument we're made were
would proved not to be terribly
meritorious but at the time I actually
think and I may be wrong again the lack
of proof on so many fronts may disable
this particular use context but I
actually think that our failure to win
consensus in a Security Council had as
much to do with our decision on Kyoto
our core to attach unilateralism on the
International Criminal Court
our bypassing the Global Health Fund our
backing other repressive regimes in the
Middle East and not clarifying why this
one was somehow different but pretending
that the others kind of didn't exist
this idea that we can just go and make
what sound to us like good arguments in
the moment without seeing the ways in
which again other decisions Guantanamo
you
they all infect you know what it is that
we're trying to argue for in the moment
so when we think you know farm subsidies
just a domestic issue well no actually
to the rest of the world it's the issue
that's helping contribute to the loss of
lives and certainly the loss of
livelihoods all throughout Africa that
they don't have a chance that there's a
fundamental hypocrisy to talk about free
trade and and and when we talk about
liberalisation in the in the Middle East
the speech I read you a portion of and
we don't really make mention we don't
not even really but we don't make
mention of atrocities in Chechen or
these boiling killings in Uzbekistan
countries that we need in the moment for
the warrant ISM when we continue these
policies of expedience there's just no
way that our words are going to be heard
on their face and of course there is a
contagion effect of the decisions that
we make and the Expediency that we use
just to read you a quick line here from
Hosni Mubarak just after some of the new
US policies were announced after 9/11
including Guantanamo Mubarak said that
the new US policies proved quote that we
were right from the beginning and using
all means including military tribunals
to combat terrorism there is no doubt
that the events of September 11th
created a new concept of democracy that
differs from the concept that Western
States defended before these events
especially in regard to freedom of the
individual the Bush administration
agrees with Machiavelli that it is
better to be feared than light but I
think what all great American presidents
and leaders have recognized or at least
the few that we will have consensus on
but all leaders charged with maintaining
this delicate balance between Liberty
and security what they have recognized
is that it is important actually to be
feared but it is far more important to
be respected and what one the United
States the respects of the world and the
security that we now crave was not
actually what we stood against but what
we stood for
it wasn't our hard power but our soft
power our ability to make others want
what we want and right now unfortunately
because
of this loss of legitimacy both for
structural reasons and for the reasons
that I've mentioned that are new and
remedy bol others want to want what we
don't want and I think the best
guarantor of u.s. values and us security
of principle and of interests is a
heightened commitment to principles like
human rights rule of law civilian
control of the military and issues that
we apply and principles we apply only in
the breach and only when no other
interests are seem to be at stake in
opposition thank you and I look forward
to hearing your thoughts and comments
questions
we can see yeah yeah a few it's really
tricky I mean a lot of what I described
especially in the first part of the talk
about the structural impediments to
integrating human rights concerns into
foreign policy these are these are would
be true of just about any state you look
to what I mentioned at the end in terms
of a historicism I mean you really I'm
scratching my mind to think of a state
that has actually chosen to remember
harms that had is inflicted that wasn't
under the barrel of the gun like you
know Germany or Japan or that wasn't
itself the product of regime change like
South Africa or something I mean now
Germany apologized for atrocities
carried out and against the Herero but
that's what happens is even the cult of
remembering or the or the culture of
remembering gets gets integrated and I
think you can have some collateral
effects having been under the barrel of
the gun and so on so I take the question
I mean it's it's really really
challenging to come up with models but
but there are some I mean you have for
instance in Sweden and in Canada and the
two off cited models you know much
higher shares of GDP being pumped into
foreign aid programs much greater
commitment for international
institutions which takes the edge off
you know military deployments now
America is gonna have great difficulty
taking the edge off anything given the
disproportionate power but I think part
of what would have to would have to
change and it really is cultural in that
you would start to one of the reasons
Canada and Sweden can get away with
Canada in particular can get away with
peacekeeping and and and just forever
you know deploying to 18-hour
maybe to Congo you know in the next
round of Congo deployments and is that
every Canadian boy grows up wanting to
be a peacekeeper apparently it's like on
your birth certificate and although
somebody said to me about Canadians is
he cited to me the number of Canadians
that lived in New York City I forget
what it was you know some number of
thousands of Canadians lived in New York
and II said you can tell them apart
because they're the ones who say thank
you when the money comes out of the ATM
machine so it may actually be more than
a peacekeeping thing there may be
something else going on there that is in
the water perhaps but in Sweden too you
know just as their domestic political
structure is much air is much more on
the side of Social Welfare it just
becomes part of what you know Sweden
Swedish nough Slyke or swedishness is
for so a lot of the forces that I
mentioned in terms of you know ripeness
to be led in this country become
actually just much more potent political
variables in in in countries like that
in the sense that you know it's part of
what it means to be a citizen and so to
deviate from that culturally actually
there can be a political cost or at
least there's a fear of that such that
people are moved by the prospect or the
prospect of a cost so there ain't aren't
really great models except for you know
kind of smaller powers I mean you know
most of the major powers are themselves
you know much worse human rights abusers
and then then certainly the United
States even with its Guantanamo and its
and its civil liberty infringement s--
after 9/11 so no it isn't it isn't
pretty out there but the United States
has you know really unique power to use
its leverage also on other on other
entities I mean certainly other states
are much more prone to contribute
peacekeepers and to invest in
international justice and international
institutions that themselves then at
least in principle developed kind of
transcendental lives and bank accounts
and minds of their own and and even as a
first cut to be much more supportive of
those endeavors which would sort of take
it out of the nation state which is
structurally so disadvantaged when it
comes to human rights and move it to
structures that are both accountable to
States and to NGOs but that actually
stand
something else and aren't forever
answering to constituencies and so on
but it's really hard because we talk
about these transnational structures but
ultimately they remain so beholden to
states that that it kind of you really
have to get the domestic politics in
these countries right or presidential
leadership or executive leadership in
order for there to be a filtering up
effect where these institutions actually
become viable and effective yes ma'am
it's a great question and when I
mentioned the lack of trust I mean
obviously this is this is there's a
tremendous skepticism as you may know
there's been this big kind of wave of
debate about humanitarian intervention
where that phrase has been tossed in
favor of this idea of the responsibility
to protect but from talking to African
leaders and citizens and that's would be
the continent I would know best I'm sure
it's true imagine it to be true also in
the East Asia in Central Asia but they
hear responsibly to protect it's the
same they hear the same thing I mean
they don't it it doesn't buy them
anything you know it may work on
whatever it may it's alleged to work on
Western audiences so that it's you know
they're not framing it in terms of a
right of intervention and but it's
somehow a duty and they think there's
going to be more resonance to that but I
mean again you've got to come back to
domestic politics and leadership and
calculations of interest and that's
what's going to make people you know
commit to these kinds of ventures so
calling it a responsibility to protect
just sounds paternalistic whereas a
right of intervention which is how it's
framed in the 90s sounded like we can go
anywhere we want cuz we've got it's all
right you know because we're speaking in
the name of universal principle so I
would say that that the that as flawed
as the UN Security Council structure is
and again there's not a person I don't
think anymore anywhere except for maybe
France
the leaders of France who would defend
the Security Council composition but but
i think i think as flawed as it is
because it's the only show in town the
you know deference to the procedural
check and to the UN Security Council
should give away only in the face of
massive you know a threat of imminent
you know massive loss of life as in the
case of genocide and in the case of
Kosovo arguably anyway a preventive
genocide but what then has to happen is
is not just the intervention and well
but it was righteous and therefore
shouldn't be apparent to everybody but
but much more you know kind of
preventive or not prevented but much
more public diplomacy on you know
engaging with African Amin this
conversation has been basically white
people getting together and telling you
know developing world countries you know
what
humanitarian intervention is how it's
necessary they said the other and the
victims like the Rwandan Zoar the
Liberians are desperate for it but all
their neighbors you know see it as being
you know necessarily about diamonds or
about timber rights or about you know
oil or or al-qaeda so I think to to just
even recognize what you're talking about
about this level of suspicion and and
and and skepticism combined with and
it's very hard to do this Alucard you
know making our policies more grounded
in in human rights across the board so I
mean that's what that's the only thing
eventually you know that will actually
erode the suspicion and make you know
policies articulated on those grounds
taken at their face is actually you know
doing more of them for those reasons and
not waiting until the al-qaeda cell
turns up in order to to rally troops
from other countries the thirdly final
point on that I would say the United
States really has to we're in a very
very perilous place right now because
the United States is is despised and
mistrusted despised by its foes and
mistrusted by just about everybody else
and yet there's no other leader on the
international stage who in the face of
humanitarian catastrophe stands up and
and exerts any leadership so what I
would also say
knowing that none of the reforms that
I'm proposing are the changes in US
culture are gonna happen anytime soon
is that actually as unpopular as we are
it is actually still incumbent on us to
take a diplomatic leadership role even
in countries that we've no intention of
having any and rightly so because we're
so discredited at present but military
enrolling so Sudan is a great example of
that where we even as unpopular as we
are the United States still just has as
it were undue leverage over so many
countries so I think you know not taking
an all-or-nothing approach and actually
you know again when you don't care as
much about a problem that's the ideal
scenario by which you work through the
United Nations it takes it in you could
this is a perfect moment for the
Europeans to make the United States look
really silly or create a very
interesting moment by bringing before
the Security Council the possibility of
an indictment around the massacres in
western Sudan so this is something that
that okay so the United States doesn't
of course want to get involved
militarily in Sudan it's got this peace
process it's got working with Khartoum
once again but here's a chance for
France or Britain to come forward and
say we're gonna refer something to the
ICC are you really gonna veto the
investigation of the murder of people on
the ground simply that they're that they
have black skin no of course you know
can't do that and of course if John
Bolton has his way they will veto it but
that's a moment and that's an
opportunity you know for the United
States to stand back in the interest of
something larger than their own again
short-term need yes sir
bad path but but interesting moment I
mean right now I think the fear is being
appropriated and harnessed and in a very
in a dangerous set of directions I mean
and it's being and just apart from that
and in the context of the war on
terrorism there's an awful lot happening
in the world that we're having nothing
to do with because we're so focused on
this and so I mean just in every and non
path bad path and on path but you know
when you I mean I in in traveling around
and talking to people in America one
does sense I'm focusing on the part of
your question that involved a moral
imagination and and the idea of politics
kind of having a bearing on statecraft
potentially but but one does sense I
mean a much more aggressive curiosity
about the rest of the world one does
sense
I mean ironically again a resonance to
bushes
you know moral appeals I mean which was
all it would have always been my
argument the context of genocide is
actually that the policymakers were
forever under estimating and and then
use it underestimate the American people
and then using not coincidentally using
the American people as an alibi for
their own unwillingness to take risk
that and and and and unwilling to do
anything that wasn't seen to be
themselves you know in their own in the
short term national interest so there's
something going on that actually it's
it's ripe to be channeled in in quite a
different way I mean the temptation is
always going to be there especially
after another
attack to kind of route you know we need
that is I would hate it's human nature
but but it's certainly proven in the
number of the few security crises that
America's had certainly proved to be
American nature I mean in and that's in
Guantanamo itself doesn't have a
distinguished history if we think even
about the the detentions of Haitians you
know with HIV you were sort of
quarantined and I mean anything that is
other that is different that is
dangerous
put him in Guantanamo somebody should
write a book that's literally like the
history of what happened in you know
within those walls but I think where
that can tip is when and already you can
feel it bubbling up but when the
awareness of the cost to the very things
in whose name those lunges occur when
the cost to security reveals itself and
it's a very difficult empirical case to
make I mean it's all maybe for those of
us here and kind of consensual New Haven
it might be very obvious that you know
anti Americanism is bad for the war on
terrorism it's just harder to fight
threats when everyone hates you that has
to be true right but that is actually
very controversial and very hard to
prove because the claim from from some
in Washington many I mean the people
making decisions in Washington is well
you know I mean no one wants terrorist
threats in their neighborhood they're
gonna collaborate and cooperate
regardless of whether we do Kyoto and
you know go through multi-multi blah
blah you know there is a sense that
these are compartmentalize Abul but I
think you know if American I hate to use
the language of culture but if for a
long time we've gotten used to seeing
ourselves as an exceptional nation the
the gravity of the threat provides a
moment for a leader to say you know what
we have bypassed the international
institutions in the past but we never
had transnational threats quite like
these you know what we haven't done
international law but you know no one
has more to gain from enforceable rules
of the road than the most powerful
superpower in the history of mankind you
know the there are ways to do it
but you know I work for Wesley Clark and
the campaign's
I'm you know I I've lost my guy you know
and I I root for the Red Sox I mean I'm
not the person to look to for for
prophecy yeah Monique yeah
but they don't eat you have names do
they do they it's Willie right ya know
it's a very good question I as you know
but maybe people here don't know in
Monique was this extraordinary human
rights activist who Clinton
coincidentally had met at a Human Rights
ceremony she'd gotten an award in
December of 1993 so when the genocide
started in April of 1994 he was obsessed
with the fate of Monique and and in this
instance human rights groups used that
personal connection and just the way
you're suggesting with him as an
individual and that was what they worked
and they worked and they worked it and
he I mean he went for it was Monique
Monique who we got to give money I want
every I want no reason to spare we don't
give and no no she wasn't like it wasn't
that kind of thing Monica
Monique yeah no no no no no not to my
knowledge anyway but but anyway the
government the the people surrounded by
him his cat everybody responded they do
that's what it looks like when you know
we know also from George Bush George
Bush wanted Saddam Hussein in the
Taliban gone guess what George Bush and
we wish Saddam Hussein and the Taliban
are now are now gone President Clinton
wanted Monique saved guess what
miraculously somehow she was saved I
mean it actually was a series of
miracles but also just everyone knew the
price to be paid if you know Monique was
actually harmed but the effect of that
is you know from your question in the
government was exactly the opposite from
what we thought it would be you know you
would think that the part would come to
stand for the whole and that thus you
know once you empathize with one person
that you can you can sort of you know
map that you know just the way you're
kind of suggesting you know cross you
know the faceless but in fact once
Monique was rescued Clinton lost
interest in the Rwandan genocide so
actually tending to the part became a
substitute for tending to the whole and
I think that is the danger actually but
there are other ways to but I but I
think it's better than I mean certainly
speaking in terms of abstractions and
speaking in terms of hundreds of
thousands of tens of thousands I mean
you know you end up needing to get to
such a high figure especially in the
wake of Rwanda now when it comes to
atrocity
genocide especially that just as the
Holocaust provided too high or low a bar
for Rwanda to measure up in real time
now Rwanda is in such a place that it's
very hard to get for instance people
interested in Sudan because it's only
you know fifty thousand or a thirty
thousand or something who've been killed
in the last few months so numbers are
not gonna work on a lot of levels people
can I think single individuals but not
just profiling them and the kind of so
and so you know is lost or this or that
but bringing them to Washington you know
getting them to testify there are very
few members of Congress who can
withstand actually those kinds of
encounters and appeals and moat as you
prep know from the book I mean most of
the upstanders the people who flipped
and turned and went from being
bystanders to actually standing up in
the system were people who had it wasn't
an abstraction and who had had those
encounters and then the other thing I
would just say is it's not just the the
victims and the survivors that can that
can provide the human drama that can
mobilize people
I actually think also finding that
individual whether it's the Dallaire or
the the the international person within
the field who's who is the voice for
what should be done whose very
prescriptive but who'd show rather than
tells if you know what I mean like some
house shows in his work or her work or
within the US government I mean to be
able to expose policy clefts and
divisions in real time is a really
really good way of then creating the
sense of possibility among advocates it
kind of feeds on itself like in Rwanda
there was no dissent at all within the
government and so even the advocates
were kind of like they didn't even know
what to root for and the editorial
boards were quiet I mean he it was in
Bosnia like everyone knew the State
Department's just split people were
resigning and that embolden other people
because they were sort of validated and
believing that you should care and that
things could be different so I think as
journalists or as human rights advocates
or citizens you know finding those
people that are both your shepherds in
terms of information and as it were
you're kind of you know mascots as you
say you know for advocacy it's really
important yes sir in the back
I don't think I don't think the the
reforms can be a prerequisite because
the United States is gonna be the main
engine for reforms and all you mean
nothing for instance on the Security
Council can happen you know without the
United States as a be told we have a
major clog in the Security Council
because all reform is dependent and and
all power relinquishment is dependent on
those entities that don't have to
relinquish power by virtue of the
Charter because they have the veto
deciding to relinquish power so we have
human nature is being tested as you know
and in the form of states I think in a
very interesting way
do you give up power when you don't have
to and I saw none none of this un un
reform is going to take place without
American leadership and enthusiasm but I
don't think it can be I mean I think the
the tone of it has to be like that that
I think Richard Holbrooke managed in the
tail end of the Clinton years he managed
to you know revamp the UN dues sort of
structure I mean yet the UN dues paid
and revamped the billing and the and the
sort of payments and lower UN US
contributions in certain areas but he
did it by working with Congress and kind
of demystifying the UN I think in an
important way and you know it's a longer
conversation probably you know to get
into about what are the defects and so
on but basically I think the UN is
largely the side of it that we know as I
suggested already is a building I mean
the UN is a building and blaming the UN
for things like Rwanda and I have lots
to say about CO
specific responsibilities maybe I'll say
a word about but blaming the UN for
Rwanda or for Bosnia or for Iraq now and
it's literally it's like blaming a
building it's like blaming Madison
Square Garden when the Knicks don't play
well you know you you when states come
together and they operate on that stage
and they can't Forge consensus it is the
fault both of the usually the issue and
of the states and the inability to forge
consensus and it is a space for those
disagreements to get played out now you
could say well but it shows that UN law
or international law isn't binding on
States and yeah that's true but again
that's less the product of the law which
again I'll say worried about meets needs
some some work but it is the product of
those who won't adhere to it or
interpret it differently and who can't
forge consensus on so in terms of let me
just give you an example of where the UN
has to behave differently in the context
of Rwanda which I mentioned in Kofi
Annan so UN peacekeepers were sent to
Rwanda by the Security Council the
Security Council five permanent members
and ten other states sent 2,500 troops
into harm's way to patrol a piece three
months in advance of the genocide the
commander on the ground got word that
militias could exterminate at a rate of
a thousand every 20 minutes sent a fax
to Kofi Annan in New York who's the head
then a peacekeeping not not the
secretary-general at the time he got the
facts and he said oh [ __ ] a thousand
every twenty minutes my god wow this is
terrible this peacekeeping mission you
know can't persist in this in this
context this is something Wow and he
said but if I bring this to the Security
Council the states that sent these
troops there and were very reluctant to
send troops to begin with they're gonna
say I'll bring the troops home and if I
tell my commander if I if I allow my
commander to confront these militias
then we're gonna get mission creep and
it's gonna be Somalia all over again and
then and then the member states are
gonna be unhappy again so maybe I just
want to show anybody the facts okay that
is a problem with the UN I mean that is
you know that's not what you do you
you cannot and this is what what UN
officials have done all the time in
their desire to stay relevant and again
to occupy the land of the possible and a
kind of you know keep thing I mean
knowing the member-states indifference
or lack of interest in a lot of these
places and they try to will the problems
away know what you need to do I suppose
I think I think and may have learned
this anyway
Brahimi issued this report just
articulating this very lesson you don't
internalize the constraints imposed by
the Member States you externalize them
you force the spotlight backward belongs
which is on the very states that sent
those peacekeepers into harm's way you
leak the facts if upon presenting it to
the Security Council you have failed to
generate the support that you need to
and to confront militias who can
exterminate at a rate of a thousand
every twenty minutes and if you do that
at least you can live with yourself
three months later if in fact a genocide
ensues I mean imagine being the person
who buried the facts thinking well the
Member States really wouldn't go along
with anything more but never actually
testing the waters and again in testing
them perhaps even altering them and then
just in terms of the UN Charter I think
it's it's just essential to to recognize
that that in a nuclear age there are
actually new threats I mean it this is a
charter written it was written and I
suppose in the nuclear age but but that
issues like proliferation really do
warrant some attention I'm not making a
case at all for preemption but
generating a discussion that makes the
United States feel as if the Charter has
actually been tailored toward these new
threats and not merely to cross-border
aggression which is not I mean which is
really what the whole UN you know peace
and security side of the UN is is geared
toward and the same would be true of
internal threats like failed States it's
there's just nothing in the UN apparatus
as such that has has kind of kept up
with the with contemporary threats
humanitarian and security so all of that
I think needs to be reworked but it'll
require you
participation and leadership okay yes
sir
yeah I mean I the the work I think of
Peter even you're probably referring to
which is so I think important on what
the international community the way in
which a state that was systematic Rwanda
which was systematically ethnically
cleansing and occasionally murdering
Tutsi could be seen to be a good
governor just by checking a number of
IMF boxes even though it was you know it
just wasn't you know none of the
international financial institutions
incorporated the fact that you know half
of its Tutsi minority was living outside
the country desperate to come home but
were precluded obviously the goal would
be you know for that to change and and
the way again just back to the
discussion about the UN the way
institutions tend to change is when the
states who shape them change and the
United States I mean Ernesto probably
has many more thoughts on the if he's
then then I do but you know if the
United States itself hasn't chosen to
prioritize atrocity prevention you know
it's gonna be the rare international
institution that on its own decides to
go against the most powerful states
wishes or even not go against it cuz the
Unites States might just assume that you
know massacres would be taken into
account in certain cases but but without
leadership or without some kind of
engine coming from somewhere in again
ideally someone else would step forward
into this vacuum where the United States
doesn't seem to take leadership of these
issues where there is a problem in terms
of a major problem in terms of US
legitimacy to speak on these issues
right now
that you would see some kind of
leadership coming from someplace but you
know I do think it will be again that
the more powerful states within the the
financial institutions that build in
these kinds of
area but of course would be for it oh my
god
oh my god he's not really the president
Mexico he's